here to talk about that and more is
assistant to the president for trade and
manufacturing Peter Navarro Peter thanks
for being here just gonna say right now
we're not interested in going into our
corners but let me ask you a question as
it relates to this hydroxychloroquine
number one then I take the position one
way or the other but why is it so
animated when it comes to this I think
basically the the nevertrump er is the
Trump haters you know left-wing media
anything he's four they got to be again
but but let me tell you a couple of
things that I think are important of
course this is the decision between
doctors and patients but if you go for
example to the Food and Drug
Administration emergency youth you use
authorization notice that's right I'll
Rev I'll just read it it says although
limited scientific information is
available it is reasonable to believe
that hydroxychloroquine sulfate may be
effective and what we've seen now is
there's there's a number of studies out
that have some preliminary evidence that
suggests efficacy not just for
therapeutic value but also for
prophylactic value we have a wide scale
test in the state of New York we should
get some results back in Ford Hospital
in Detroit let me tell you the ginning
what I did over the last week since the
task force last Saturday we could go
Saturday the task force unanimously
approved surging hydroxy into the hot
zone so my team team Trump basically got
19 million doses of hydroxy first into
four of the hottest zones Chicago
Detroit New Orleans in New York and then
we went to some additional cities down
line a lot of them we read like NFL
franchises and you know it's Baltimore
its Washington it's Houston and also in
addition the Veterans Administration
asked for a million doses we got that to
them and DOD won and default partner
defense wanted at a million doses we got
back
to them so there's demand out there and
there's a protocol and let me just say
one thing the protocol in the FDA it's
very clear what they're doing it's a
five-day protocol you take a double dose
the first day next four days a single
dose and I think well let's see what the
scientific evidence says and then I'll
go back on with that guy and we'll Duke
it out again CNN but but but is there is
there is there a competition is there
something else I know we're waiting for
the data we're waiting for the test the
stage is the vaccine but is there
something else
I mean you know in my open I I put in a
sound of the woman who was a Democrat
from Detroit a how a Michigan
representative who said you know thank
God for Donald Trump even mentioning
this and once I got on the hydro chloric
would hydroxy I was fine well you're
open to a spot-on no it's just come on
it's like never never Trumper is it's
like oh if he's for it we got to be
again it but I'm telling you that it's a
slippery slope there on here because
anecdotal evidence at the front lines
not scientific but it tells you that
that doctors and health care providers
are using the stuff like M&Ms as a
prophylactic to prevent them from
getting sick so let's see where it's at
but the science has gotten to a point
enough where it's reasonable for the FDA
to approve emergency use authorization
and it's you know there's literally
millions of doses out there and the rest
of the world's fighting for the rest of
the doses prevent you know some won't
even let it go out their borders so
something's going on with hydroxy and I
think the president's going to be proved
absolutely right again well it but and I
think I think that the interesting thing
is that when you talk about the is part
of an FDA protocol I mean that's pretty
serious but you know we'll wait to see
what happens but in line with that there
are as we try to fight this virus and
thank God things are getting better
right now we
come to recognize that there are certain
treaties or agreements that we have with
other countries to get whether it's a
protective personal protective equipment
or you know ventilators or whatever else
there might be and they're not actually
delivering pursuant to their agreements
what does this tell us in terms of where
we go when we actually open up again or
even before we open up well judging my
mission here at the White House right
now 24/7 is to figure out how to make
sure the supply chain delivers the
essential medicines the medical supplies
like masks medical equipment like
ventilators to the American people at
the frontlines in this war against the
virus and one of the first things I did
in that mission was to break down the 30
different things you need to treat a
coronavirus patient and what was what
was shocking to me was that virtually
everything on that list came from
offshore and the problem in a pandemic
is that when your supply chain for your
medicines and your medical supplies are
outside your borders what we see as
countries acting like nations which does
is say they protect themselves and right
now judge there's over 75 countries that
have imposed some form of export
restrictions on things like
hydroxychloroquine on things like masks
and and it's a situation where if we
learn anything from this crisis it's the
lesson of Donald Trump you got to have
both secure borders and you got to have
your manufacturing on shore and what we
need to do over time is make sure that
that we can manufacture everything we
need on shore and there's a couple of
ways to do that first of all it's it's
imperative that our government agencies
buy American is the VA HHS the
Department of Defense they buy large
quantities of drugs and equipment as in
Medicare and Medicaid as well it's it's
imperative that we going forward by
American when we can we can do Larry
Kudlow and the president been talking
about a tax break where you give a
hundred percent expensing
for investment in the pharmaceutical
but yeah but Peter III got Marsha
Blackburn who's gonna talk about that
she's the next guest but you know you're
right in there Peter when when do you
think we can open reopen this economy
boy that that is the toughest decision
President Trump and any president will
have ever have to make let me just give
you a quick perspective on this here's
here's the problem you got you got the
the purest medical professionals
basically taking the position that that
the the way to minimize loss of life the
only way is to keep the economy and
society shut down until the virus is
vanquished
and and they're they're half right
because that that will minimize the
deaths from the virus directly but what
we've learned particularly from the the
China trade shock and how it affected
the Midwest communities what we've
learned is that that that an economic
shock a China virus economic shock will
also kill Americans we learn that from
from what we saw in the Midwest we saw a
higher depression rates higher suicide
rates higher morbidity we saw an
epidemic of opioid deaths so we know
that the virus itself kills but we also
know that economic recessions and
depressions kill and so that very tough
decision this president is going to be
making is to have to have to weigh the
balance and figure out which which path
does more damage and in the meantime
we're going to do everything to protect
people at the front lines of this and to
the extent that we can get things like
antibody testing and testing for for
infection there's tools deployed out in
the field that will help us better get
people back to work if you have somebody
who takes it antibody tests and has them
they can go back to work so tough choice
for president Trump you're the same
person who'll make it right we're right
no credit I want to thank you for being
back I want to thank you for being back
on Justice feed
and good luck to you and your mission